i'm not into your fight that's between
y'all you keep grouping us up like it's
us against you
the aftermath of kendall and kylie's
fight on keeping up with the kardashians
continues i don't know it was like
really i mean i wasn't even that
emotional at least i didn't think i was
kendra you've been a rude person for
years i'm about to tell you the truth
about how you are you don't apologize
for nothing you get into one thing now
you got something to run and harp on
then you tripping
yeah corey gamble is basically choosing
sides and giving tough love
to kendall i don't trip though
kiss my ass i don't need nobody kissing
my ass what the hell are you talking
about
everything was wrong i mean believe it
or ever you want to i ain't tripled
safe to say kendall is not happy i'm
already
pretty frustrated with the whole
situation and hurt and offended
cory he's just not right in this
situation
and i'd rather him just admit it say
sorry
and man up this family we feel like it's
a revolving door
of course the argument made other family
members not want to choose sides
chloe kim and courtney have tried to
stay out of it
and mom chris wants no part of it either
i mean i don't like being in the middle
i wasn't even a part of it and i feel
stuck
i'm sorry babe it's just a really tough
thing
i hate it the rest of the season has so
many
crazy things going on by episode's end
both kylie and kendall
seem to want to forgive and forget
there's been multiple times in the past
couple days that i've um thought about
calling her and just being the bigger
person
i love my sister i think that we'll
figure it out just like we always do
um yeah it was just an unfortunate
situation she was tune in because you
never know what's going to happen